the one that the only the best brent
musburger how are you sir I am fine I am
fine can't wait can't wait for the Super
Bowl we come I hate this week off rich
you know that and but the money just
keeps on slowing lad
so where do you where do you alright
let's let's start before we get to the
Super Bowl where do you what is your
take on what the NBA seemingly proffered
to the state legislature in New York
State saying that if gambling is
legalized state by state if the Supreme
Court makes a ruling and state
legislators can now legalize gambling in
their state that the NBA wants one
percent of a cup what do you think of
that
right well like every operator I laughed
when I saw it not going to happen wait a
minute you've argued for decades that
gambling in in Nevada
threatens the integrity of your game and
now you want a 1% integrity fee not not
going to have a rather interesting
though rich from the standpoint that the
NBA has been ahead of every other
professional league in accepting the
reality that gambling on sports is here
to stay whether the Supreme Court allows
New Jersey to accept those bets or not
you can gamble globally offshore you
could go to a book in Costa Rica Panama
if you're under London if you're down in
Australia if you're in Hong Kong
you can bet but the books are not about
to start handing over 1% of the take
first of all first of all there's this
misunderstanding of how much money is
made by gambling on sports the sports
book here in Las Vegas
4% is a pretty good hold when you take a
look at what happened it was four and a
half billion debt last year I mean all
these records are their public records
they have to file their income tax
reports and everything far more money
ladies and gentlemen is made on slot
machines and betting on sporting events
so but it was it was a Florida that
fascinated me and all the operators will
take dead aim against it and not going
to happen now I think as the NBA
confront in a state like new you
simply because they've got teams in the
NBA good luck going to New Jersey where
you've yanked a team out and put it in
Brooklyn and say kind of give us 1%
assuming there's gonna be legalized by
the Supreme Court and speaking of the
Supreme Court rich yes the other thing
is I'm going to assume that more than
one of the justices saw the report and
it's a wait a minute you're asking for
you you want to become part of the
bookmaking operations of course we
should legalize so I think that that
probably is going to help the
legalization in New Jersey if I have to
read the tea leaves but I don't think in
the end what the NBA has to do is just
what they've done over Europe without
Australia here's what you do is you sell
the rights within your building and the
advertising rights to the different
casino operators who book sports so what
do you but you you know the NFL better
than most brent musburger do you think
the NFL will ever even if the Supreme
Court makes its decision open arm
embrace what you have open arm embraced
in this part of your career Brent well
because they've approved the Raiders
move to Las Vegas and I Drive past a
construction site not every day but
every third day I'm by their
construction site and there's a bridge
there over interstate 15 which I can
walk from the Raiders stadium to a half
dozen sports books on the strip and make
a bet on the NFL so if they're not
embracing it they better give me a good
reason why because you put up a stadium
within walking distance of betting out
your games and unless they have got
technology that I'm unaware of you'll be
able to sit the stands and make a bet
during the game Brent Musburger joining
me here on the Rich Eisen show what do
you think of the XFL gambit that got
announced yesterday by Vince McMahon
Brent oh you know a publicity stunt I
don't I I don't pay a whole lot of
attention to that but if he goes through
with it and we got teams we'll put a
spread up here in Nevada we'll talk
about it sure sure you will all right
let's get to the big one Super Bowl 50 -
how are you reading this one Brent well
I've been following the money here rich
and the big money and some big money has
fallen and it's fallen on the Eagles MGM
which operates ten different sports
books here in the Las Vegas area had
Philadelphia plus five and a half and
they took a multi-million dollar pack a
couple of million dollars and maybe even
more after the juice was paid they took
the Eagles in the five and a half and
MGM quickly dropped it to four and a
half even if you want to Patriots money
on that so they're they're begging for
Patriots money and then a little bit
later in the afternoon yesterday a
better came into the South Point and bet
a half million dollars on the money line
taking the Eagles a couple of the big
offshore shops had already dropped it to
four and a half although I do see this
morning that five dimes and went back up
five so some paper his money I showed
there and that's a Costa Rican book and
so most of the big bets have been on the
Eagles and that doesn't surprise me from
the standpoint that last week the
Patriots had to come from behind down
with it was 14 to 3 and 1410 rallied
against a listen a good but not an
outstanding Jacksonville team especially
on the offensive side of the ball
there's been a lot of criticism by
gamblers in Nevada over the conservative
play calling by the Jaguars in the
second half and the Eagles were lights
out lights out there was a lot of money
better of Minnesota and and and the
Eagles just tore them apart and Nick
Foles look like the the second coming of
but John Elway or Peyton Manning and so
the betters are always influenced by
what they see last I really haven't
decided myself which I I'm waiting to
see the Gronk is cleared from concussion
protocol
I assume that he will be although he
didn't play last year and that's right I
see James white Kettleman Amador they
all had great games for Tom Brady and
it's hard for me to go against I had
Atlanta poultice poke I had a planet
last year watched it wilt away they had
some questionable play calling down in
the in the fourth quarter
a Belichick and Brady had this wonderful
ability to become become when all hell
is breaking around them and they wait
for the other side to make a mistake now
let's go to Seattle at the one-yard line
bypassing LeGarrette Polanco in a pass
intercepted at Super Bowl victories of
the paper they seize the moment and
better than any team that I've ever
watched in the National Football League
and when you make a mistake especially
in the second half it's going to be
lights out they're very calm under
pressure and I think that gives them an
advantage although long and and blood
are now over on the other side and they
can certainly help the youngsters on the
Eagles in preparation of what goes on I
noted yesterday that the Eagles worked
in pads that means they're putting their
heavy work in as John Madden was the
first coach to discover put your work in
in that week before you go to the side
of the game then you've got to go to all
the news conferences you got to go to
the parties and you do just some light
work once you get to the site which is
Minneapolis in this particular case so
listen I've got such great respect for
what the Patriots have accomplished over
the years but this is a very good
Philadelphia Eagle team and the NFC at
my opinion was a little bit stronger
than the AFC this year so you know again
Brad there's a couple of questions I
want to ask you here before my bosses at
the NFL have a complete coronary overall
the amount of money that you just
mentioned what why shouldn't they have a
coronary over something like that Brent
I mean when they hear that sort of money
being laid down is there no concern at
all that some nefarious forces can
somehow infiltrate Super Bowl 50 to give
me that response here well what's Tom
Brady's salary you know it's through the
roof buddy yeah yeah okay all right so
if you're gonna if you're gonna fix an
NFL game which player which position
forget a name which position are you
gonna start with nominally I'm going to
give you an asterisk on this because we
all know we would choose the quarterback
okay
sure and way back in the days in the
thirties of the professional football
teams there was a lot of rumor and
gossip about certain quarterbacks
gambling on games if you went to mr.
Brady and said listen I'd like it just
to kind of keep this close just win this
biopsy of color so it would cost
billions and billions of dollars for you
to tear it to hammer into one of these
professional athletes whether it's
professional basketball major league
baseball I am NOT concerned about that I
do think I do think that you have to
watch your officials I think you have to
watch them very closely
I think they have to undergo checks
because I think there as we have seen
with the NBA over the recent decade you
have to be with I'm not concerned about
any professional athlete today in in one
of our major leagues simply because of
the amount of money that they make and
and how much it would take to convince
him to shave points or try to do
something I'm not concerned about that
you do have to be where your NCAA
athletes I said it time after time
however it will not do to legalize
gambling on professional sport in this
country and not the NCAA because it's
going to go on anyway we know what's
going on billions of billions of dollars
are going to be bet and the global books
around the world and of course new
jersey leading the way wants to get his
hands on some tax dollars under
understandably so
listen certainly the NFL should be
careful and beware but the bookies are
their best friend the bookies are
absolute best friend do they happen for
decades but they don't understand
they're the ones what the honest game
because all things considered equal they
just want to get up middle they got the
pig they're gonna wind on that now most
of the time it's not because you do not
have equal money on the two sides so the
so the bookmakers have a position
usually with the underdogs that they're
pulling for to win outright to help them
on the house the league's don't have to
be concerned in the case of the National
Football League especially the National
Football League
it would not under any circumstance be
as big as it is today without people
taking a position on the game now I'm
not talking just about the guys I
suppose
talk about the $2,000,000 better the
half million daughter I'm talking about
the man demand for dinner to five the
$2,200 pest or the leagues that you play
in without even point spreads picking
the winners or you play another leagues
where you pick maybe five if you got a
confidence and you vote them down five
to one
this helps fuel the interest in the
National Football League and how about
fantasy they signed it with fantasy the
biggest fantasy in the world are the
operators of the NFL franchises trying
to convince me that's not gambling last
one for you Brent I got about a minute
here what is Super Bowl fifty two for
Brent Musburger we're gonna watch it
later I'm going to watch it in the
studio if he said because we have been
experimenting rich during the NCAA final
game the Alabama Georgia came okay and
last week during the conference
championships with in-game wagering
which is the fastest growing type of
betting and they change the odds based
on first down certainly scores field
goals touchdown they freeze it the three
primary bets during the game will be
point-spread moneyline over/under and
there are people around this globe
that's the only bets they make they will
not make one before the game but they
will go in they will sign into their
gambling account and they won't fire
away as a game unfold and it is very
very fascinating of you let me give
everybody an example last week when
Minnesota opened up 7-nothing quickly on
that opening drive you could get the
Eagles for seven and a half points you
could have the Eagles with seven and a
half and Gil Alexander one of our hosts
at beast and he was right with be on the
air life he fired it took it and and the
rest is just four he was a he was a
winner on the other side of it we had
somebody fire on over-under he lost his
head so it's a in the form of wagering
their game unfolds Brent you're the best
thanks for the call well chat soon okay
got it
five always that's Brent Musburger for
more Rich Eisen show tuned to audience
channel 239
Direct TV or download the Rich Eisen
show app